unless you get some fresh air so I guess
if you're a fan of fresh air I love AC I
could never be out so I hate outside
I'll see you in there yeah it's freezing
cold ha ha ha there burn if to yourself
you take a shower yeah and I'm not
complaining because other shoes are
horrible from what I heard roaches
there's no Roach problem in Coleman
which is great because I hate roaches so
I know guys in Florida too
oh yeah yeah but they've got you know
look look the prison is it's it's clean
you know it's a pretty new prison it's
really the garden spot of the VOP most
prisons are just disgusting they're
falling apart
so that shoe although the fact is that
you are separated from everyone you
can't you can't really you can and you
can't really get visits depending on
what you're secure what your level is
it's it's not that bad you know I like
after three weeks I remember Thomas is
in for like two three weeks and usually
they'll come they'll bang on the door
they like [ __ ] you want you want to
sell you they'll say you take in sally's
and you're like you know no no you know
you reading no it's freezing cold at
night it's free they let you choose
where they want to sell you one sheet
that's what sucks is you don't get a
pillow you get one sheet comforter oh
god you're Bowl you're balling up your
clothes they use it as a pillow it's
miss and you're freezing your ass off oh
of course I can't give you a [ __ ]
hoodie they don't care about your
comfort so your bet they're paying on
the do you want you taking Sally's and
you and you're like no no then after two
weeks it's like yeah bro give me
somebody somebody in here anything and
then they'll put some guy in there for
you know two three days and you guys are
talk and you'll talk like I'm like
[ __ ] 24 hours straight you know his
whole story he knows your whole story
and then three days go by and it's like
you go oh as long as you're okay with
each other you know what else
so yes it's not it's not look it's it's
bad I hate to say it's not bad it wasn't
bad for my personality type and then
some people are surly then right and
some people ain't keep mine it was I was
the medium I was below I actually went
to
that actually went to the shoe at the
pen hmm so I used to always say this I
used to say when people I thought when I
get out and people ask me where'd you go
to prison I can say well you know with
the Coleman I did a little bit time in
the / in the pen a little bit of time
the medium and I finished out my bid
it's a low and that is true I was in the
shoe at the pin for one day as a federal
pin the federal pin for one day
terrified I mean listen my way on my way
when they put bring me into the shoe and
then I'm shackled and I'm walking in
literally on my way there I'm like bro I
said you can't put me in with one of
these [ __ ] and they're like
[ __ ] don't worry we're pretty you know
they were so nice that CEOs were so
quiet you know what because they're like
he's from the low look at this little
fella they knew he like bent over but my
god these guys I don't appreciate that
but these guys are vicious well I mean
you would have right there are a lot of
rape that goes on in those prisons [ __ ]
yeah the problem is this people think
that is that they're violent right
there's plenty of wait ways to rape
someone it they can just pressure you
where you think you're gonna get stabbed
right for guys walk in on you with
[ __ ] shanks what will you know have
you heard store at scene that [ __ ]
happen I've heard that happen yeah or or
guys and think here's a problem is
there's a ton of a matter of fact I got
a story in here this is like the most
embarrassed um there are keep them on
there are gay guys in prison right so
you tell me if you're some guy with a
life sentence and you're you're you're
prone to homosexuality maybe on the
street you wouldn't have been a
homosexual but in prison [ __ ] it I got a
life sentence yeah you're gonna you know
there's it's not like they're all taught
they they're all macho guys know there's
[ __ ] there's had a thousand guys
there's 20 gay guys and there's Louie's
[ __ ] transgender that look like
woman's yeah that's like Jake told us he
was like rage guys in there that are
even they're just they're just gay yeah
they call it gay for this day they yeah
one of our friends said that some people
just leave it at the gate they say that
when they
the gate I was what the guys will come
to prison pick up a Bible and then like
be in the church all the time for four
or five years and then when they leave
they basically drop the Bible back down
in jail
so whatever it takes to get them through
it you know either God or sucking dick
you know one of those oh one of them to
God maybe a little both
[Laughter]